bienvenidos a mi presentación de las
propiedades de los logaritmos y esta
presentación va a ser una presentación
bastante práctica así que si no crees a
alguna de las propiedades que te voy a
decir no te preocupes en tres o cuatro
vídeos voy a demostrar cada una de estas
propiedades por ahorita quiero que crees
una cierta instrucción y que además
trabajes un poco con estas propiedades
de los logaritmos pero bueno vamos a
hacer un pequeño repaso de lo que hemos
visto si yo tengo a espera espera esta
no me gusta vamos a ponerlo en color un
poco más nítido y un poco más fuerte
está a meg usted más no no no mejor
vamos a empezar desde el principio ha
elevado a la vez es igual a cm esto es
un lenguaje exponencial todos lo
conocemos ya habíamos dicho que en
logaritmos podemos decir que esta
expresión es equivalente a decir que el
logaritmo en base a déjame escribirlo
aquí el logaritmo en base a de c es
igual
avn de c es igual de bien sin embargo
hay que tener mucho cuidado porque
aunque estas dos expresiones son
equivalentes no solamente tienen que
decir lo mismo en
acaso si nosotros nos preguntamos cuál
es el resultado de elevar a la potencia
bien pues nos hacen sin embargo aquí lo
que tendríamos es un problema parecido
pero no el mismo ha elevado a qué
potencia me da c y la respuesta es ven
si te das cuenta el concepto es muy
parecido sin embargo aunque estas dos
expresiones son equivalentes muchas
veces las podemos manejar de maneras
distintas pero bueno por ahorita dejemos
de lado al exponencial y vamos a
enfocarnos en los logaritmos y la primer
propiedad de los logaritmos déjame tomar
un color diferente déjame tomar este
color la primera propiedad de logaritmos
es la que sigue y voy a poner logaritmo
en base b porque b es la base del
logaritmo
entonces voy a escribir el logaritmo en
base pda + logaritmo en base b en la
misma base de sem esto es exactamente
igual y ojo me estoy tomando una suma de
logaritmos en la misma base el logaritmo
en base ven de la multiplicación de a
pulse logaritmo en base de d
por cm y habíamos dicho que yo no voy a
demostrar estas propiedades en próximos
vídeos lo voy a hacer sin embargo
ahorita quiero que hagamos un poco de
intuición acerca de lo que está pasando
cuando estos logaritmos así que déjame
hacerte un ejemplo supongamos que yo me
quiero tomar el logaritmo en base 2 de 8
creo que el 2 es bastante buena base
entonces logaritmo en base 2 de 8
logaritmo en base 2 de 8 lo conocemos
entonces lograremos base 2 de 8 más
logaritmo en la misma base es decir en
base 2 d
voy a suponer 32 16 x 12 32 exactamente
el logaritmo en base 2 de 32
esto según las propiedades de los
organismos tienen que ser iguales y
vamos a ver si sin que el logaritmo en
base 2 de quien de porsche es decir de 8
x 32 8 x 32 8 por 2 16 llevamos 18 por
324 256 256 el organismo en base 2 del
256 y si será cierto esto
esto es lo que vamos justo es lo que
queremos averiguar así que vamos a
desarrollarlo voy a ir resolviendo cada
uno de estos logaritmos a ver si se
cumple esta igualdad así que déjame
resolver cada uno estos logaritmos para
ver si se cumple esta igualdad y ver si
realmente estamos en lo correcto
logaritmo más de 2 de 8 es decir 2 a qué
potencia me la 8 pues la respuesta es 32
elevado a 3 es lo mismo que 8 por lo
tanto el hogar y no en base 2 de 8
estrés ahora tengo el organismo en base
2 de 32 2 elevado a que potencien me da
32 2 por 2 4 por 2 8 por 2 16 por los 32
a las 52 elevado a las cinco me da a 32
entonces logaritmo en base 2 de 32 5 y
bueno esto queremos que sea igual al
hogar en un base en dos de 256 y cuál es
el logaritmo en base 2 de 256 yo sé que
no somos computadoras que no sabemos
todas las potencias de 2 pero clement 2
elevado a la 8 es 256 y no solamente
estoy diciendo la 8 para que quede esto
todo podría ser aparte te vas a dar
cuenta que 2 elevado a la 8 es 256 y
perfecto entonces este cumple porque
tres más 5 es igual a 8 y entonces acabo
de enseñarte que si funciona la primera
propiedad de los logaritmos y eso tiene
mucha lógica porque fíjate bien si yo
escribo en lenguaje exponencial 2
elevado al cubo por 2 elevado a las 5 2
elevado a la quinta potencia esto
sabemos por las leyes los exponentes que
es 2 elevado a la 35 es decir los
exponentes se suman esto es 2 elevado a
la 35 que por cierto 2 elevado a 35 de
12 elevado a la 8 por aquí va mucho la
lógica de la demostración de esta
primera propiedad de los logaritmos aquí
que yo tengo lugar en un base pda x se
me estoy refiriendo a 2 al cubo por 2 a
la quinta y aquí que tengo yo el
logaritmo en base de a más el logaritmo
en base etc me estoy refiriendo en
demostración a 2 elevado a la 35 pero
bueno aquí ya tenemos la primera
propiedad de los logaritmos que dice que
el logaritmo en base de a más lugares
esto es exactamente igual que el hogar
es un base de aporte y de igual manera
acción pero aquí con un logaritmo que
tiene adentro una multiplicación lo
puedo separar en dos sumas de logaritmos
de logaritmos de la misma base que por
cierto utiliza nuestras propiedades de
los exponentes que tenemos aquí abajo de
amarillo ya suena con mucha más lógica
que se pueda cumplir esta propiedad de
los logaritmos porque de hecho déjenme
borrar la pantalla y voy a escribir
ahora la segunda propia de logaritmos
que vamos a ver en esta ocasión la
segunda propiedad los logaritmos también
es muy parecida tiene toda la lógica del
mundo dice que el logaritmo en base
recuerda que ven de base lugar en un
base de d
menos logaritmo en base b deseen esto es
igual y a quién crees que sea igual si
seguimos con la misma lógica de los
exponentes esto es lo mismo que el hogar
y en base b de a en 13 del positivo
entre el negativo ojo eso es muy
importante y bueno tengo el logaritmo
base de al menos en un base de s igual
el logaritmo en base b de en 13 así que
vamos a ser un ejemplo siempre tomo base
2x
3 porque la base 3 también es bastante
interesante aunque hay que tener un
poquito más de cuidado el organismo en
base 3 de base de un noveno vamos a
complicar un poquito más logaritmo en
base 3 de un noveno menos a no ser
logaritmo en base 3 recuerda que tiene
que ser la misma base de 81 esto a
cuánto es igual bueno según lo que me
dice la segunda propiedad de los
logaritmos esto es exactamente igual a
logaritmo en base 3 d en 13 es decir de
un noveno entre 81 por 1 entre 81 es
exactamente lo mismo y que por cierto
esto cuánto es igual esto es lo mismo
que logaritmos base 3 de un noveno por 1
sobre 81 1 por 1 1 y 9 x 81 me da 9 por
una 99 por 872 1 en 3 729 es decir el
logaritmo en base 3 de 11 en 3 729 1 en
3 729 y bueno será cierto esto pues
vamos a verificar lo lugar
en base tres de un noveno tres elevado a
que potencia me da un noveno bueno yo sé
que tres elevado al cuadrado me da nueve
eso lo voy a escribir aquí tres elevados
cuadrados igual a nueve entonces tres
elevado al menos dos es igual a uno
entre nueve recuerda que cuando nosotros
sumamos la misma potencia negativo
hablamos del recíproco entonces estos
menos dos menos lo ganen un base 3 de 81
3 elevado que potencia me de 81 y pues
bueno 3 elevado a la 4 es 81 por lo
tanto tengo menos dos menos 4 porque 3
por 3 9 por 3 27 por 3 81/3 elevado de 4
81 que por cierto menos 2 menos 4 esto
sí lo sabemos cuánto es esto es menos 6
y yo lo que quiero ver es que 3 elevado
a la menos 6 en efecto sea 1 en 3 729 o
dicho de otra manera el logaritmo en
base 3 de 1 en 3 729 sea igual a menos 6
a ver 3 ha elevado a la menos 6 quiero
que sea igual a 1 en 3 729 esto es
exactamente lo mismo que decir que 3
elevado a la 6 729 y si será cierto esto
pues 3 elevado a la 6
de la siguiente manera esto es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarme 3 al
cubo por 3 al cubo 3 al cubo por 3 al
cubo y 3 al cubo yo sé que es 27 es
decir 3 por 3 x 3 entonces no quedaría
27 x 27 y bueno tú lo puedes alguna
calculadora no puedes creer pero 27 x 27
o 27 al cuadrado de 729 y bueno se me ha
acabado el tiempo de este vídeo pero en
el siguiente vídeo voy a ver las
propiedades de los logaritmos que me
faltan así como más ejemplos de todas
estas nos vemos en el siguiente